kingman arizona is notable for two
things
it sits on the historic route 66 and
four years ago
it delivered one of donald trump's
biggest wins anywhere
my name is becky and i'm a volunteer
with the
arizona republican party at the
republican party hq here
they're aiming for a repeat you don't
quit calling me
i'm not gonna vote okay honey
polls show trump could lose arizona this
time
not that they believe that here there's
more enthusiasm they say
so when identical twin volunteers karen
and carol arrived
another trump text message
we joined them for some canvassing on
the streets of kingman
what was it that motivated you to get
active politically it's so important
that he get re-elected
so that our country doesn't go down the
tubes well i felt like i had to do
something too
and you think the enthusiasm is still
there oh oh it definitely
is definitely okay so i'll mark you both
as voting for trump and mcsally
the polls said one thing in 2016 and
then something else happened
you think the same thing will happen
again that there are people who will
come out there's the same kind of
momentum do you feel there's people that
are scared
to say they're voting for trump i'm not
no he wears his trump hat everywhere
but away from kingman arizona has a
bigger story to tell
and the signs literally seem to be
worrying trump supporters
some republicans pulling for his
democrat rival in the face of extreme
hostility
we've had vicious comments social media
comments
vicious letters vicious emails you know
you're unworthy you're this you're evil
you're i mean all these things and these
are people we've known 15 20 years
that we've gone to church with for 15 or
20 years trump is not a a unifier
trump is a divider and hopefully
you know biden uh will be able to unify
and if trump's president for another
four years it's just
it's going to be extremely difficult and
that's why many of us that are
conservative
are working very hard to see biden get
elected
even though we don't endorse the whole
platform but because we do believe it'll
be an opportunity for our country to
come together
another factor here is the growing
latino vote traditionally democrat
leaning
but pollsters say trump's campaigning
hard to latino men
on the image of being a strong job
creator all he has to do is win
enough of that latino vote to make it
impossible for democrats to put that
winning coalition together
so vice president biden's going to win
the latino vote
and he's going to win latino men the
issue is does he win them at 55 percent
or does he win them at 60
and 62 percent and we need to get into
the 60s
to flip this state in particular
arizona's one of half a dozen states
where this is playing out and where
the futures of donald trump and joe
biden will be decided
greg milam sky news phoenix arizona